at least eight people have been killed
and dozens injured in a crush at the
africa cup of nations in cameroon the
incident took place at the entrance to
the olembe stadium in the capital
yaounde reports indicate crowds tried to
force their way into the stadium to
watch cameroon's national team play
comoros the game went ahead on schedule
with fans inside the stadium unaware of
the deadly scenes outside
with us now from boya in cameroon is
correspondent blaise young blaze thanks
for joining us tell us more about what
happened there in yaounde last night
uh a very sad day for cameroon normally
at this time cameroonians will be
running the streets because the team is
qualified to the next stage for the
african cup of nations but that's not
the case because like you mentioned in
your introduction eight persons died
yesterday as some of these fans tried to
rush into the stadium to have access to
the stadium why cameron was playing a
game uh uh against comoros and according
to police sources
on the ground they said that these
people try to force their way into the
stadium and that's when the stamping
happened immediately some of them were
taken to the hospital but before that
we've had confirmed cases of at least
eight people who have died
so we've got those figures but what are
residents and officials in yonder saying
about the crush could it have maybe been
prevented
so far information has been very little
from cab and also from government and in
this morning the health minister and
also the secretary general of cap visits
on people who sustain injuries in
hospitals
in terms of the local population they
are angry because information is not
coming in on exactly what happened how
it happened also people are angry that
security forces outside the stadium
could not contain because the population
the the fans rushing into the stadium
actually overpowered the security forces
that were stationed outside to control
the crowd so people are angry and also
there's very little information coming
from government and also coming from cap
could there be consequences blaze for
the remaining matches in the tournament
perhaps stricter crowd control measures
prior to this competition kavak already
restricted an amount of people
who can access the stadium so now in
this incident uh we may find ourselves
in a situation where uh all the
tournament you find itself in a
situation where a cab may say okay all
the other matches will go without fans
or maybe they'll bring down the number
of fans that can go to stadiums as maybe
our viewers may know uh as of now 80
percent of the capacity of the stadiums
can be filled when a match is played by
the host country and 60
for
teams that are not
the host country
that number could actually go down not
just because of kobe but because of the
incident that the
deadly incident that happened last night
blaze thank you very much for bringing
us up to date there that was
correspondent
blaise in where cameroon